no guarda veramente ci sono rimasta
malissimo fra con me non si dovrà
comportare codice ci conosciamo da una
vita cioè con la foto madre che poi sono
anche a cena fuori tutta la tua famiglia
mi ha portato nella city è una cosa
veramente ci sono rimasta male aspetta
un attimo c'è tu cosa avreste fatto al
mio posto cioè non ti sembra normale che
comunque la situazione si era quella che
si passa da davos cursore vuole estate
amici star zitto facciamo parlare
vabbè non ci si fa ma ti prego
dell'ambiente va bene avevano detto che
se presa male per i figli perché gli
horror fanno colbert che non sarai tra
spetti ai muoio tuti sangue normale se
sono i che son esagerata potersi fast
hanno posto
questo ci fai che uccide 32 però che
proprio questa mettere festa no vabbè
però questo è un complotto cioè non vedo
niente via fastidio tono è scusi grazie
scusate ma no non ho fatto la spesa e
scusate questo è imposta scusato e mi
piace partecipe 9 mar dati dei tipi di
no cretina che ti tradisce lo sanno
tutti
allora molto anche l'altro incredibile
guarda guarda che inquadrato riguarda la
pulizia della fotografia grazie grazie
cemento perché andare in cina se dormi
cioè state la casa o street e
liberamente questa scena per poi ritorna
nel finale perché poi lui va da lei alla
fine cioè va bene lo dico da versare mi
ricorda vagamente il cinema sovietico
gli utenti io non me l'aspettavo ci
aggredisce alla fine così non è stato
perso
c'è chi giura chi è questo qui ti lascio
certamente sei insopportabile pagato
biglietti questo è il pd internet così
non ha aggiunto il fuoco duraturo
io scusa
il giorno d'oggi